okay and we're back people in our back
we're playing that secret this is part
two and this is a really good game okay
babies let me explain why this is the
real test the game is good or not is it
okay you play it pause walk away I don't
care what you do to take a [ __ ] put your
penis against the jar mainly I don't
care what you do but during that time if
you yearn to get back to it that's what
it is okay baby so that's what happen to
me okay we just got out of that little
like crazy people room so what we got to
do is last thing I think we have the
jars I've got to put on the leeches in
there you know what I'm saying that I
you know what I'm saying okay so that's
got a lot of jump scares in this game
yeah nice okay and
ok marrick ok let's say that's my
chachos let's fell the liquid I said yes
yes yes filled each bottom with a leech
ok get kittanning leeches yes [ __ ]
Maseca scalars opinion
Oh
oh I think that the defrost that i knows
froze it
I put this [ __ ] on here
oh yeah oh yeah baby
I
am I saying something
Reiner is a lot
sir like a pot I could put this up
now
[Music]
oh yes okay
[Music]
that's outside
is this like gonna be like lemon had a
[ __ ] i get over there
yes babe a tank lemon juice weekly
groceries claims at his Prague
hmm
holy [ __ ] obviously turning evil
okay anyway i geti get away these
leeches I think share it goes hair cuz
they pay
it's really quiet [ __ ] scary
say the obvious up share
yes c is the heaviest
all right yeah yeah
ok let's see as the heaviest I think
it's a recheck here but II and then I'll
put day okay I and D D is the lightest
he's a little heavier than a okay Jamie
Shane let's stay in this match
move move to the right position okay
search the basement freezer
okay this is gonna be [ __ ] terrifying
but let's do it i guess you know let's
do it I'm looking out this way I'll [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
I can't get down that guy that was close
I'm stuck down here but I find the light
switch well email he's not down here cuz
he's up there so what's so scary you
know what is so scary
okay what lights was just got around the
wall so let's do this how's that nice
at second scary
okay now lie to a chair
[ __ ] is that noise war
where's a light touch
spring cleaning
what is it here
[ __ ] is the light switch
and
what cutter has been harassing her where
it goes [ __ ] that's [ __ ] scary okay
here yay um here yay
these batteries don't [ __ ] around now
that's all i gotta say i have you
stopped night fought in three days I've
been giddy ever since I figured that
this might be a murder case not even a
broken arm could keep me down now that
I'm here the truth seems a lot more
complicated the story is my shot better
make it count okay ouchie brickyard was
broken in the beginning
Oh
unknown chemical what the [ __ ] am i
doing
hey batch
that always there
the woodcutters grand wellington
okay well it looks like we got to go
back this way holy [ __ ] mark asset we
need that doing any other shut Oh record
[ __ ] is that
okay we got trying [ __ ] on
where the [ __ ] is the lighter
anything that I'll light it now
i turn the [ __ ] up for a bloke the whole
[ __ ] place what is that Oh
feel Jays s he's getting my dick sucked
in a hurry
ah let's take a look in here out in a
cab Abby says he use that [ __ ] that's
in here oh I see now any [ __ ] in here
I repeat any [ __ ] in here are you
enjoying yourself
wow this guy is saying graham is like
insane oh no Sathya and this poor guy
this guy's not doing well I have to say
okay anyway
wow I have to break the ship with the
chemicals that are like corrosive okay I
got to find like a flint though
so let me take that hey hey betch
I could go in there
lemon juice
hmm
big toolbox
can't go back upstairs can I
oh is that shovel [ __ ] half I get in
there
this lady it's [ __ ] slow gentle
pretty tight does by why I cutting up my
nerves you know
ok need to find the chemicals i donate
yeah yeah yeahs touching my body
touching my slaves oh there's like a
side opening on this hey what is that
ah I say wow that was a really good
lucky fine like I helping us makes it
rusted shut and a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
all rusted
Oh what the [ __ ] about some matches okay
finally I can light that [ __ ] your
nightmares in here anyone I can't bad
chance okay no chess all right guy right
here copper sulfate hey I'm chloride
should I [ __ ] rested topical are at
exxon packs on Borak the [ __ ] is parks
that all up but let me do something
what was the [ __ ] that I needed
where's the notes
there we go
borax and lemon juice that's what it is
okay
boy x is here yep
okay batches yeah I'm ready for a
[ __ ] jump sky already it's been a
while it's been a while
another passage i can get out of here I
could do everything else so that could
like used to get in China
Oh seemed to beckon wanted [ __ ] was it
retribution no money gram Wellington
he's the what cutter yes Bullard was
being black lazy but Josie oh no no no
all right that Jess
shits can scare now
but you know I need to uncover the case
okay I need to uncover the case that
water is [ __ ] gross let me get like a
trench foot you know [ __ ] gangrene
the [ __ ] down there I'll buy a shirt
on it oh [ __ ]
duh [ __ ] was that
that [ __ ] [ __ ] he knows I'm
traveling did he just like standing
outside her well
well he's not gonna [ __ ] yet thing
that was like 30 feet up above shut
there we go here we go oh I'm in the
room like next to the kitchen
[Music]
Papa's I'll [ __ ] monkeys in here
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
use this thing as if there's that
something up there rank of wood what is
that I open these doors
[Music]
me that's pretty good i got a man should
I weird i don't have again by Paige
[Music]
main patas completes
the weather condition is sensitive mr.
carefully
[Music]
he noses up to something
[Music]
she liked you more time
[Music]
conflict off yes nice and calibrate
hey turn out fine eat there
let me just check the bottom floor a
little bit more and then I'll go up
there shut came through there anything
notable in here no
we'll check out this box
do you care [ __ ] there's definitely some
dude around here
okay what's going on
china get out there ok just trying to
get up there [ __ ]
[ __ ] bobby was in here right in his
little shut
alright
Cicero's and going down set up Rosanna
right
so there
[ __ ] is that Oh blade wait can I read
this oh my god they keep bullet in there
or they yelled yellow Graham Wellington
wanted fame and glory Josie Herrera
wanted to find something precious
Cynthia peckmon wanted money hey Bobby
Sawyer wanted to be a writer I wanted to
get out of Kansas and start a real life
now I just want to see my mother again
yeah very sad very sad ok this up and
waiting for me down there
can I take this channel off
okay what looks like I'm going back in
the house of the record player here now
damn pay on out I got to get back to the
basement oh yeah a lot of [ __ ] the jail
I forgot that you know what this ass
[ __ ] okay it's the [ __ ] dream
apparatus
oh [ __ ]
ok [ __ ]
ok
got
[Music]
I say there's some
[Music]
now
[Music]
right there at that hi dad
that was I saying
a [ __ ] died yeah my dad he's like wow
wow wow but yes nice to meet you
that's yes okay
or the [ __ ] do I exit
time is something is on
shut up this
tuxedo he's burning [ __ ] share the
[ __ ] fire I'm that that okay okay
can I go
what the [ __ ] of this oh my gosh gonna
look again in the trash can
el maraa I'm a
ok
hear him walking
please come back here
you
[Music]
think about this for one sec
can I go in there for us oh [ __ ] yeah i
Ken doing here
heck a [ __ ] there you go
that's the answer I'm looking at the man
I kinda [ __ ] on
[Music]
shut what's he gonna dick castmate you
got to kiss me they're gonna kiss make a
summer okay
[Music]
okay okay i'm turning Wyatt Oh
it's a trump machine that makes any race
you are white okay
and there's as many doors you know you
just gotta get to the end baby okay yeah
just got I got to the end Wow I playing
this game I gone to the end come on Matt
I love that there
I playing white boy
that
how FAR's does then go chef I don't even
know what's going on here it's an infant
at all
[ __ ] going on here
what is this game I playing this white
boy okay
I Elena's Wi-Fi game okay oh I think it
happened triggers when you try and go
backwards yeah that's it Wow yep already
who's at the end now ready so I was
going to an infinite loop right there
you know what I'm saying is I'm gonna
try to crack my [ __ ] and I don't let
anyone just cranked my pase I like I
need them it's not you had at it and was
the killer oh hello sorry
grandma okay put me in the dungeon hey
put me in the dungeon that's that's
great
alright alright
yeah that's a large crack baby I've seen
Emma lon up to the pain is crying up a
lot of things on my penis let's just do
this okay okay [ __ ] ok no [ __ ]
feel okay just like a great where's the
feel Cynthia I know you had it
James larios chef
who is full of that I'd like that out
I'd like some answers I say is if
raising bear bell
Hampton moonshine
that's at
let's see if I can burn this shat as
there
okay come on crank this shot
that's a damn good question
let's get the [ __ ] Eddie out [ __ ] how's
that
anything else in here though
now that [ __ ] here I'm getting out of
here
now is that bench
yeah the [ __ ] am I
how's Eddie
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] out here
yeah that's not gonna get any boy
oh [ __ ] that wasn't Bobby James it's not
Bobby yeah Graham holy shut
what the [ __ ] of that and I'll find out
shat hair goes
[ __ ] is that
a chi batch
[ __ ] just getting around here don't like
I say
[Music]
ok I get the basement
[Music]
[ __ ] scary ready what's gonna happen
now someone in here somewhere right here
[Music]
there goes what are we gonna find out
now
[Music]
by a black page how the document today
the telegrams are confirming
hmm loi just escaped
[Music]
okay well I guess this is the end we
gotta go check out the Fraser we got it
got out I hate to say it oh [ __ ] yeah
okay batch already knew where I was
going some you can cut that out
[Music]
there we go what's in it I'm gonna die
in here that's for sure hypothermia
kills in a matter of hours and leaves no
Marc Bullard died in his freezer or was
it James Lowry now that I've gathered
all the pieces I just need to put them
together a scientist with a past a dead
colleague and ex-wife down on her luck a
girl with no father and a boy with no
future snow woman the full moon now I
just need to get out of here alive
Shay's ass
[ __ ] sacagawea's hunting me
packing Sacagawea is hunting me okay you
know what that feels like [ __ ] socks
match
back in the doctor and what is this
oh it is this the [ __ ] hot we're all
right
lot of clicking they get [ __ ] carpal
tunnel oh I have to decide who the [ __ ]
was
[ __ ] it was Graham Wellington
how's that guys where why can I go
anyway
shot take out my SS okay okay well I
guess that's one ending we see if I
could do another one got out here all
right hello hello okay okay I nice a
nice well anyways I guess it's not in
the game I want so you can just like
pick the endings shut anything then
these death
oh okay let's just say it was this bench
and a [ __ ] snap hypothermia I guess
right change this it's so sad i want to
go real person is
pick Bob rasayana
let me guess walking in the snow [ __ ]
in the snow
okay that shape she kicked the bucket
she kicked the bucket okay kick that
lockout way now way now
join the fray I get the last hunt show
that she was a little too nice the whole
time
you think a do you know how chef
[ __ ] this [ __ ] talent it you're crazy
that Josie
the [ __ ] is going on here
okay where can I go
it was that [ __ ] it was that [ __ ] sha
Allah
and they asked
[Music]
you should be ashamed air stop telling
you should be ashamed of yourself I
barely managed to pull Josie from the
house as it burned to the ground all of
Bullards research his equipment and his
secrets burned with it mm-hmm top i
right Josie Herrera was arrested for the
murders of Harris Bullard and Graham
Wellington my story of blackmail murder
and my narrow escape from a deranged
killer made headlines in january i start
at the chicago tribune okay I never told
them about James Lowry or that Josie's
last name is really Turner those secrets
are mine alone
[Music]
okay i think if i don't see where it's
another anything
tell me I'm afraid okay that's like it
hey UMP that strange
Sarge as a
ok this is uh nothing
[Music]
okay I barely managed to escape as a
house burned to the ground all of
Bullards research his equipment and his
secrets burned with it the bodies of
Josie Herrera and Graham Wellington were
recovered from the debris my story of
blackmail murder and my narrow escape
from a deranged killer made headlines ya
betta betta yeah bet at Chicago Tribune
I never told them about James Lowry or
that Josie's last name is really Turner
those secrets are mine alone
what that will be the next one that
[Music]
give me a sec to think pass
[Music]
okay am I gonna end this real quick
okay I'm looking at right now and the
last ending is actually if you run away
when you see the leave thing on the
ground so might we need to follow the
one knows I got to leave on the ground
once you like jump out the first time
you're being chased if you actually run
away it's an ending saying like that
okay let's see if we can get that ending
real quick
[Music]
okay i guess i can anyway that's the
game thank y'all pup lion that kava
plant you like this um we have a comment
i guess and we'll see if any other good
ones to play you know what I'm saying I
guess case solved by psychobabble and
now hahaha goodbye say yeah